Doctor Strange is undeniably fun from start
to finish.
By introducing the mystic arts, the multiverse,
and a whole lot of Dormammu, the Benedict
Cumberbatch-starring superhero sorcery story
keeps Marvel Studios' streak alive into the
latter half of 2016.
But it's not perfect.
Call us nitpickers, call us buzzkills, call
us acolytes of the dark dimension, but we're
about to dive into some of the less magical
aspects of Doctor Strange's plot.
While its story is actually really tight overall,
there are still a few niggling plot holes
and contrivances that you can't simply wave
away with the Wand of Watoomb...
"Teach me!"
...no matter how hard you try.
Oh, and it should go without saying, but let's
say the magic words anyway: massive spoilers
ahead.
Insecurity system
The movie begins with Kaecilius, played by
Mads Mikkelsen, breaking into the Ancient
One's library to steal a couple of pages from
one of her very favorite books.
These books contain the most advanced knowledge
and spells in the Ancient One's possession.
They're pretty important!
That must be why she keeps them loosely draped
in chains that appear to be entirely decorative.
It goes without saying that Kaecilius needs
to steal the pages describing the ritual for
the movie to, y'know, actually happen, it
wouldn't have taken much more on the movie's
part to make it a little harder for the bad
guy to actually steal them.
And hey, while we're on that subject, why
didn't Kaecilius just take the whole book?
Of course, if that happened, then the book
wouldn't be incredibly easy for our hero,
Doctor Strange, to take a look at when he
needed to learn about the rituals later in
the movie.
Speaking of which…
Oh, hey, Kaecilius
Isn't it weird that, on the night that Strange
wanders into the magic library, when he reads
from the book with the missing ritual pages
stolen by Kaecilius, when he teaches himself
how to use the all-powerful Eye of Agamotto
that can manipulate time itself … that's
the very night — the very moment — when
the villain decides to launch his attack on
all three magical sanctums, including the
library itself.
Not only that, but it also happens literally
seconds after Doctor Strange says that he
won't be "dragged into some sort of mystical
war!"
That's bad timing, Doc.
Next time, why don't you try saying,
"I've got a bad feeling about this"
Or maybe…
"I don't know how much more I can take."
"Aahhh!"
Those words, too, must be powerful spells
that magically compel the plot to move forward
at the most dramatic moment.
Eye, oh my...
While we're on the subject of that scene in
the library, Wong and Mordo both seem pretty
unhappy about how Strange went and started
messing with the Eye of Agamotto.
The two tell him about all the terrible consequences
that could come from monkeying with the timestream,
and then they put the book back.
Just one thing, though: why didn't they take
that big honkin' amulet off of him, too?
Oh, it's so he can have it during the villain
fight that's about to take place for the rest
of the movie?
Oh, okay.
That's cool.
No time to explain
We hear a vague list of consequences that
the world might possibly face as a result
of Strange's experiments with the Eye, like
time loops and alternate timelines or something
equally unspecified.
And, hey: we all saw Back to the Future Part
II.
Nobody wants Biff Tannen to take over the
world and get down with our moms.
"Noooooo!"
But aside from the time loops that were admittedly
part of the extremely clever and satisfying
climactic battle with Dormammu, we never actually
learn anything concrete about the dangers
of screwing with time.
It kind of seems like there might be no actual
consequences at all, despite Mordo thinking
that they're dire enough to leave the good
guys and become a supervillain by the end.
But what was really so very bad about using
the Eye to save the entire planet from being
sucked into the Dark Dimension?
Kung fu cloak
Remember that wacky magic carpet from Aladdin?
The one that was so expressive and fun, despite
not having a mouth or eyes or even a face?
Well, that carpet's back — in cloak form.
That's right, the Cloak of Levitation is the
magical item that takes a liking to the good
doctor and helps him in his battle against
Kaecilius and his goons in the New York sanctum.
It's pretty handy.
Except … when it isn't, like when Doctor
Strange gets stabbed in the chest.
And literally any other time after its initial
introduction.
The cloak seems to have a mind of its own
and acts as an important ally for Strange
on his heroic quest — but only when it's
convenient.
Otherwise, it's just, y'know, a cape.
But a fancy-looking cape!
Two sanctums, or three?
We learn from Wong that there are three sanctums
protecting the world from evil.
Kaecilius and his minions take down the one
in London, and destroy the one in Hong Kong.
And that's when Dormammu's Dark dimension
starts to come through.
But the New York sanctum is still standing.
So how many of these things does the world
actually need?
Follow-up appointment
Regardless of whatever plot holes or hiccups
we think we may have found here, Doctor Strange
was hugely fun.
When it comes to an amazing introduction to
the weird, magical side of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe, one thing's for sure: the Doctor
is in.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel and watch more videos like
the one you just saw.
And don't forget to check out all this cool
stuff we know you'll love, too!